she calls me Gugu which is kind of weird
but I like it I like Gugu just call
Justin Bieber Gugu actually don't that
interesting little pet name is reserved
for his wifey Halley Bieber she's got me
wrapped around her finger pretty much so
you say goo goo when she says Google
yeah see we're both each other's goo
Goo's it's good stuff the 26 year old
stopped by The Ellen DeGeneres Show
Tuesday and answered all of our burning
questions like how many kids he and
Haley want to have how many kids do you
want to have uh I think it's up to Haley
because it's her body and that's exactly
how you answer that question gents
Bravo jb anyway Haley she comes up a lot
he dishes on her signature scent she
smells like like ariana grande's perfume
and reveals what she thought of that
mustache right now I'm gonna keep it
clean cuz my wife she's not really
liking it you didn't like it she won't
like it
I'm with Haley on that one hard veto on
the mustachio Justin also says there's
one thing he does that pushes his wife's
buttons i annoy Haley when I constantly
singing around the house she likes it
but then there's a point where I think I
don't know I don't know what I feel like
she loves me a regardless of anything I
do but thinking around the house is not
annoying Justin okay wouldn't you know
they pay for that yeah yeah something
tells me she doesn't hate it back in the
studio
cutting the song keep on forgiving me
this one over here Haley she just every
time I do something stupid she forgives
me so there's that
yeah Justin just celebrated his 26th
birthday and according to him Haley made
his big day extra special my wife did up
my house really nicely and she had a
movie playing it was like this really
romantic night so I'm a big deal you
know it's pretty cool that's very cool
what she did up your house like like
with balloons and stuff or just you know
you basically got like a serious like
wedding planner type style thing and
like did it all in like candles it was
like this gorgeous like yes or almost
yeah pretty cool
the lovebirds also celebrated his d-day
with a bash at La hot spot Delilah the
two were photographed cuddling smooching
dancing basically schooling us all in
the art of PDA he's a good kid the good
part and I love him and just in case all
of that wasn't sweet enough hailey
recently stopped by The Tonight Show and
dished on how that moment from 2018
helped the couple who was on a break at
the time turn things back on the next
morning after the interview had aired
I got a certain phone call from a
certain someone and it was a little like
hey how are you I saw you on Chevy found
last night you were looking really good
I loved that trick that you did I had no
idea that you can do that it was so cool
cut - I'm now married to that certain
zone I mean can we blame him that really
was an epic party trick and I have this
thing he's checking the game she's so
awesome of course you can count on et to
bring you all the latest on Justin and
Haley so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens else
you soon
[Music]